here you
well, good morning.
That was okay.
I think you can do better. Good morning.
That's better.
So it has been a week, hasn't it?
I think spring is coming.
I think it's coming this week.
Sun's out today, which is a big win.
It's not 50 degrees outside. I don't think it's supposed to be this week. So
that's a big win.
It's been a big week and it was a big week for OBU.
thanks to all of our Henderson Hills friends who
joined about 200 others who came
out yesterday and helped
us clean and
clean clean debris around the campus clean debris
all through our our facilities
and God has done an
unbelievable work. I've got to tell you in a week
and I've said it before this past week,
but what a difference a week makes some
of you need that kind of renewal in your life.
If you don't know last week, I think
I can't even remember. I feel like I'm in a Time Warp. I don't know who I
am or where I am. Really? It's been such
a crazy period of time since April 19th,
but on April 19th, we were
hit with a tornado and the tornado went directly through campus.
And it hit our kind of
one of our iconic buildings. It impacted all 47
major buildings all 167 structures
across our campus 1.2 million
square feet 200 Acres.
and when the tornado hit
We had about a couple hundred students and
faculty and employees as well
as a couple of homeless folks.
Who were Sheltering at the neighboring?
Church
And that the Pastor said if a tornado
comes run to Riley chapel, and
they'll let you in they'll take care of you.
and sure enough we had a couple of homeless folks and
their dog
in Raleigh with us and God preserved all
lives no lives lost no injuries.
So it's a miracle because we
had four or five major structures or buildings structurally
damaged. And so,
you know looking at
our seniors you got to understand our seniors
started.
In 2019.
freshman year
and if you remember anything about that Academic Year 2019-2020.
fall 2019
spring 2020. Does anybody remember what
happened in Spring 2020?
Yeah pandemic. Do you remember the world shut down
the wheels fell off the world?
So I think about our seniors.
freshman year pandemic
senior year tornado
So our goal was to get everybody back on
campus to finish the semester.
And have a meaningful graduation and normalcy.
And to do that it took about on
April 20th and 21st.
about 450 volunteers
it took about 200-250 contractors.
We had three or four roofing companies out covering
our roofs drying in before the storms that
were coming on Sunday and Monday.
And we had to fill and dry in
all vertical openings where we're talking about walls blown
out or whether we're talking about wall penetrations or
you know doors
blown off or Windows blow. Now, we
had to do all that and then we had to do the moisture mapping.
Because if you know anything about tornadoes or hurricanes,
they pick up a lot of things in their
wake and a lot of water and you don't know where that water's
been or what it's been over. So it's
categorizes class 3 water which is
like sewage water
So you have to have every space tested.
and clean professionally
For OBU, that's a few thousand rooms
for 5,000 rooms.
And I've got to tell you.
We had teams working around the clock.
And I was able to say to our our entire campus
and our bison.
Nation really
that
Not only would students be allowed to come back to campus they came
started coming back yesterday
We're having in-person classes tomorrow.
Yeah, it's a miracle.
and
why would we do this?
Why would we work so hard for this?
Is it for the buildings? No buildings are
a tool.
Buildings are a resource.
We do it because God has given us the charge to invest in
people.
The next generation of leaders this group right over
here or wherever you are. I think it's over here, right?
This is the generation that's going to be taking care of
us. This is the generation that's going to be our doctors
and our lawyers. This is a generation that's going
to be our cybersecurity experts and we need those more
and more every day.
This is a generation as we found out at OBU who
are going to be our Structural Engineers our civil engineers our
electrical engineers. This is a generation that
is going to make our world tick.
more than that
Under God, this will be the generation.
That leverages all their life.
all for Jesus
That's the potential.
And our vision is to see an
entire generation.
raised up
in every sphere of life and equipped
to go into their world and make a difference for the
Lord.
in every sphere of life
and that's why we did what we did and that's I just
believe that's the potential of this generation.
I believe it.
And you see hints and indicators of this this
generation standing up and saying yeah, that's what
I want to do with my life. I don't want to waste my
life.
Fill the stadium was yesterday. Some of
you may have gone.
My son was in Norman. I mean I'm telling you.
What God's doing right now with this generation is
unbelievable. There was a Revival at Asbury
University.
And it wasn't just at Asbury. Do you know we had Revival
at OBU?
Do you know that we had Saul Revival movements breaking out
all across the nation?
Just the story a few stories at
OBU. Here's the reality. We had folks who
were far from God and yes, we've got plenty of students who are
far from God at OBU.
They're there because the world class education what we're
seeing is.
Their light was turned on.
They repented of their sins and they came to Jesus.
And the Lord saved them that happened at
OBU. We saw students laying down things that
they shouldn't have ever picked up in the first place.
And then they picked up the things of God and their
lives were changed.
We saw addictions broken.
suicidal thoughts and ideations broken
There's there's something that's happening in amongst this generation
that we can only pray is of
movement of God.
and one of the things that you find about a movement of God
This is one of those key markers of a movement of God.
There's confession of sin.
And there's not just kind of surface level repentance.
There's deep repentance and a turning back
to God and that's really what I want to talk about today.
I want to talk about dark stars.
Deep Cries and divine grace
and I believe that what happens
when we encounter God's word is our
lives can be changed and then our Our
Lives can be leveraged for the glory of God in this
world. That's what can happen.
And I think that's what God is doing right now.
I don't know why he's doing it the
way he's doing it.
But I don't care God's business is his business. Our responsibility
is just kind of get on the train and hang
on.
So we're looking at the Book
of Joel we work through chapter
one.
Today we're going to work through most in
your English Bibles of chapter 2.
Verses 1 through 27 and then next week. We're
going to go through 28 to 32.
But let's walk through chapter one and
and we're breaking it down into a few sections. So
I'll highlight those for you chapter 2 verse 1
blow a trumpet in Zion sounding alarm on my
Holy Mountain. Let all the inhabitants of the land tremble for
the day of the Lord is coming. It is
near a day of darkness and Gloom a day
of clouds and thick Darkness. You'll see this language of
the coming day of the Lord begins in verse 1. It'll
show up again in verse 11.
Like Blackness there is spread upon the mountains a great
and powerful people.
They're like has never been before nor will
there again be after them through the years of all generations. What
is about to be described as an invading Army of
the North?
Okay, and this invading Army it
kind of sounds like the Locust plague in chapter one,
but this invading Army what happens in
the next few verses is Joel is
describing what the enemy Invasion
looks like.
Verse 3 fire adapt devours
before them and behind them a flame burns. The land
is like the Garden of Eden before them, but behind
them it's a desolate Wilderness and nothing escapes
them their appearances like the
appearance of horses. Like war horses. They run.
As with the rumbling of Chariots they leap on the tops of
mountains like to crackling of a flame of fired
barring the stubble like a powerful Army drawn up
for battle before them. People are in
anguish all faces grow pale.
And this Army says in verse 7 like Warriors, they
charge like soldiers they scale the wall. They March
each on his way. They do not swerve from
their paths. They don't jostle one another each marches
in his path. They burst through the weapons and are not
halted. This is a powerful Army and what you're looking at here is
an actual depiction of what would happen
in an ancient near Eastern onslaught of
a city. It happens this way.
Verse 9 they leap upon the city they run upon the walls. They climb
onto the houses. They enter Through the Windows like a thief
the earthquakes before them the heavens tremble
the Sun and Moon are darkened and here is
where the stars don't shine anymore the
Stars withdraw.
They're shining dark stars.
Look at verse 11 you might want to highlight this or
underline it the Lord utters his voice before his
army. Now. Here's what we need to understand about this
this enemy invasion is not somehow outside
the authority of God.
And that made trouble us and I'll talk about this in just
a minute. But the reality is all the
things that are going on in the world are somehow not
outside the sovereignty or
the Authority or the rule or the rain.
of God
God is strong.
And God is mighty.
In passages like this what we find is because it's
his army. Something is going on here
in the day of the Lord.
God is judging sin.
And it's easy for us in the church to say. Oh all those
Sinners out there God go get them. But here's the reality.
It's his own people.
Who are corrupt from the inside out?
And God true to form and true to
his nature. He said hey, if you rebel against
me people of Israel. Guess what I will discipline you
and that's how we should understand. This. This is a
Divine discipline for sin. How
do we know I would encourage you to go back to your Bibles and read
Deuteronomy 28.
And when you read Deuteronomy 28, you'll understand.
That Israel is not just a free Society to do what they
want to do. God has called them for a purpose and
that purpose is to be a kingdom of priests and a
holy nation so that the world might know
through this particular people.
How God is God of all Nations the god
of Israel the god of the Covenant is
also the cosmic lord of the universe.
And through this particular people the whole world would
be built be blessed. The reason that's important for
you and me.
Is you and I our lives are in that story, too.
When Jesus came who is a child of Israel?
In fact, he's the king of Israel.
When he came he called you and I
for a purpose not just to be free wheeling and
live our lives like we want. Hey, I'm free. I can do whatever
I want. Yes, we can.
But God has called us to something more.
He's called us to his purposes.
He's called us.
To declare the Praises of the one who's called us
out of Darkness into His Marvelous
Light. So the world might know
the beauty the truth the
goodness of our God.
So when it says here in verse 11 that God
is marching before his army.
This enemy invasion is not outside the control of
God in fact.
God said this would happen.
Verse 11. He who executes his
word is powerful. That's God himself for the day of the Lord
is great and very awesome and circle this
phrase who can endure it
will come back to that question in a minute.
Verse 12 we have a turn. This is a new section.
From the focus on the day of the Lord to response
of the day of the Lord yet even
now declares the Lord return to me with all your heart with
fasting with weeping with mourning range your
hearts. Not your garments return to the Lord your God for
his gracious.
And merciful slowed anger abounding instead
fast love and he relents over disaster.
Who knows whether or not turn on relent and leave a blessing
behind him a grain offering a drink offering before the Lord your
God blow the trumpet in Zion consecrate
a fast call us all of assembly gather
the people consecrate the congregation assemble the
elders gather the children even nursing infants let
the bridegroom leave his room in the
bride her tree chamber between the vestibule and
the altar let the priests the Ministers of the Lord weep
and say oh God spare your people.
Oh Lord and make not your heritage or approach a
by word among the Nations. Why should they say among
the people's where is their God?
Here's another section then versus 18 through 27.
verses 18 through 27 focus on the restoration
of God
Then the Lord became jealous for his land and had pity on
his people the Lord answered and said to his people behold.
I am sending you grain wine and oil and
you will be satisfied and I will know more make you
a reproach amongst the Nations. I will
remove the Northern or far from you and drive him into a parched in
desolate land his Vanguard into the Eastern Sea and
his rear guard into the Western Sea and the stench
and foul smell of him. Will rise for he has
done great things.
verse 21
fear not Oh Land be glad and rejoice for the
Lord has done great things fear. Not
you Beasts of the field. I love the fact that God is talking to
animals here.
Maybe that's just me.
He's talked about the animals of the field in chapter one now. He's
saying hey guys, don't be afraid.
It you don't have to be afraid that you're not gonna have any more food. Look what
he says.
Fear not you beast of the field for the pastures the
Wilderness or green the tree Bears its fruit the Fig
Tree and the vine give their full yield be glad o children
of Zion rejoice in the Lord your God for is giving you
the early Reign for your Vindication. He has poured down
for you abundant rain the early and the
latter rain as before the threshing floor shall be
full of grain the that shall overflow with wine and oil. I
will restore to you the years that the swarming locusts. Hey,
we've got a return of the locusts.
Chapter one right now. It's back. I'll restore
to you the years the swarming Locust has eaten the hopper the
Destroyer the cutter the migrate Army, which I sent
amongst you you shall eat in plenty and
be satisfied and praise the name of the Lord your God who has
dealt wondrously with you.
And my people shall never be again put to shame.
You shall know.
That I am in the midst of Israel and that I am the
Lord your God and there is no one else and my people shall never
again be put to shame.
So I just want to offer three brief Reflections from this passage
of scripture that will help us understand what it
means to engage our God.
What it means to live well before God, here's the
first thing that we need to realize from this passage.
number one God disrupts a corrupt
world
God disrupts a corrupt world. Now
this goes back to what I was saying about the day of the
Lord you remember in verses 1 and 11 this phrase the
day of the Lord the day of the Lord is imminent. It's
near
what we need to understand about the day of the Lord this event.
Where God reveals himself in Justice and mercy, here's what
we need to understand about the day of the Lord.
The day of the Lord is God's way
of saying no.
to the wrongs
that exist in our world.
Now I want you to think about this.
Have you ever had this question man?
What is wrong with this world?
Watch the news or you read a feed
on your on your media on your platform your device.
You read and you just oh my goodness. What is going on?
What is wrong with this world?
I mean this world is jacked up.
What is wrong? This is ridiculous.
And there's this intuitive sense that things are.
Out of joint you remember Hamlet, right?
The world is out of joint o cursed spite.
Well Hamlet knew.
What we do.
Our world is out of joint.
Here's the difference though.
What Hamlet did is he said you know?
The world is out of joint occurs his spot that I was ever meant to set
it right. He took the world's problems on
his shoulders and he says I can fix this.
Here's the reality.
What's fundamentally broken and wrong with the world? We can't fix?
Do you know why?
We created the problem.
sin
And the reality is we need a radical intervention of
God.
To set the world, right?
The day of the Lord, is that radical intervention?
Where God shows up?
And says, yeah rape murder
exploitation greed. No, that's not
the order of the day.
No, that's that's not that's not gonna be the way it's
gonna be. I didn't make the world that way that's not
the way it's going to be for eternity disease.
When your body turns against you, no.
It's not always gonna be that way.
The day of the Lord is the radical intervention of
God
into the order of today where he sets wrongs, right?
The day of the Lord is an event in which God is revealed in
judgment. And/or salvation for Israel and/or
the Nations and accordance with the justice and the mercy
of God another way to say this.
Is the day of the Lord is the coming of God into the
world for salvation. You might be saying what
are you talking about? He for salvation verses 1
through 11 is all about an enemy invasion. Is
that salvation? Yes.
Why because it's purging the world of
sin?
And anytime God shows up to purge instead of
sin.
It is a creation of firming action. It is
God saying I'm going to wipe out.
the disease
so that renewal and life can come back.
So it's an action of God its salvation into this world,
which also implies judgment.
So that God can instill his reign.
Well, we know about this day of the Lord is that
wrongs are set, right and Injustice is
judged by God the tears of the
world are washed away.
Why because God wipes away the
oppressors?
Only God can do this.
It's a radical intervention of God into our
world.
Now what we see in verses 11 is it's not
far off. In fact, the language of the text says it's great and
it's imminent it's near
These adjectives are repeated throughout the Minor
Prophets that imminent and great and terrible
and near day of the Lord.
It's fearsome.
And it's especially fearsome for those who have
turned their backs on God.
Why?
For those who fear the lord the day of the Lord is
a day of Refuge.
But for those who rebel against the lord, it's a
day of Terror.
So
in verses 2 all the way through 10, we
have this picture of the enemy invasion.
And the enemy Invasion follows what you would expect when
you think about ancient near Eastern battle plans surrounding the
series City laying Siege to
it. And then at the invasion itself going through the windows
and the doorways and how those would all
be set within the city walls of the city.
And so the question then arises in
verse 12. Oh my goodness who is
going to be able to endure in the day of
the Lord?
Who?
Well, I'll get to that in just a second. But here's the
first thing that I want us to really grab hold of
from.
This picture of dark stars. And for those
kinds of those of you who are thinking gosh are
really the sky and then everything going to
turn dark and the star is gonna turn dark in the sun and moon
is what what any time in the Old Testament or
the New Testament when you have God stepping from
Heaven to Earth to intervene and set things right?
the World Turns topsy-turvy
why creation responds to its creator?
And so what you're seeing here is creation responding to
the Creator when he comes to vindicate
the righteous and judge the wicked.
What can we see from this passage?
particularly verses 1 through 12
listen to me.
Here's what you need to take to the bank. And so do I.
The wrongs of our world will not always be normal.
Injustice will not always be
normal
We won't have a need when God comes near
and makes all things new we won't have a need
for a district attorney.
If you're a district attorney in the room, we're grateful for you.
But there's going to come a time.
When you're not going to need a prosecutor.
You're not going to need a human judge. Why?
Because the Divine judge will have set all things, right.
Injustice won't be the order of the day because God will wipe it
clean. That's what the day of the Lord.
shares
Now, why is this important? I'll tell you why let me
get real personal.
City of Shawnee the tornado that we just
experienced went straight through the city. I'm part of a leadership planning to
get the city back not just normal, but
thinking forward about where our future is
and where we need to go. And what's the opportunity here
again? Miraculously, no lives lost no injuries.
But we were in this big kind of war room
kind of planning meeting on Friday. And one
of the things that came up with all these subcommittees and
you know planning groups. We need to make sure
that we have a committee that addresses fraud.
Now you might be thinking well, why would you I mean we're Emergency Services.
Okay, you know clean up
and economic development. Okay.
fraud
yeah.
You know you had folks.
Not many but you had folks.
Going to Residents who
had trees on their houses.
And with charging them four to 14,000 dollars
to remove a tree.
When Samaritan's Purse and Oklahoma Baptist disaster relief
are doing it for free.
Now, what do you say about that?
I understand tree relief and all that is expensive I
get that.
But what we saw amongst some Bad actors in
our society.
They were exploiting.
The vulnerable to make a
buck.
now
that gets in my nerves.
That flat out makes me mad.
And I look at that and I think man these people have been through so much.
And now we have to deal with this.
God is this how you made the world the day of the Lord says no.
God didn't make the world for that.
That is wrong. And listen to me.
There is in this world such a thing as right.
and wrong
and the beautiful thing is it's not terribly ambiguous.
Why?
God is showed us. What is right and what is
wrong?
And you might call me old-fashioned or antediluvian.
I am a PhD I'll use that word, right?
You might think me too narrow too
small minded, but here's what I would say.
Why is it that we recognize when things are
wrong?
Because intuitively God has built
the world according to a grain of the universe.
Where there is right and there is wrong and when
we see exploitation, we know that's wrong when we
see rape or murder. We know that's wrong. We see greed uncontrolled
greed. We know that
is wrong why because it is
wrong.
The day of the Lord reminds us when God turns
the lights off.
Because he's coming to intervene. Here's what
we need to understand.
The wrongs of this world won't always be normal
God's gonna set it, right?
You can take it to the bank.
The day of the Lord says no to the wrongs of
our world.
And I want you to think about this.
The day of the Lord is a concept that sets a pattern for
how God intervenes in our world the day
of the Lord shows up in the Minor Prophets. It shows up in the book of
Isaiah. It shows up amongst other places, but you know what
happens when Jesus comes in 2000
years ago and he appears and and
born and he ministers he
dies on a cross.
his victoriously resurrected, you know what that
is described as
the intervention of God in the world
today
remember in Matthew what happens to the
world when Jesus dies on that cross?
the sky turns dark
There's earthquakes why.
because creation response
to its creator
Sin, and wrong is not the
order of our day.
The New Testament recognized when Jesus came and
when he's coming again, it's going to be the day
of the Lord.
The New Testament follows the Old Testament pattern it
when God shows up.
It's a day of judgment and salvation
at the appearing of Jesus our Messiah.
So the day of the Lord in the New Testament is transformed
into as Paul likes to describe it or
others like to describe it the day of Jesus Christ.
or the day of Christ in Philippians 1 or
or in 1st Corinthians verse 1 chapter 1
verse 8. It is the day of our Lord Jesus Christ would
Jesus would come again? The thought of
the New Testament writers was that he would have two functions number
one?
He would judge the world and would pronounce judgment on
human beings who rebelled against him. We know this from acts
17. We know this from second Timothy 4. We know
this all through the New Testament. Jesus is
going to come to judge the quick and the dead.
second
As Savior Jesus is going to transform our bodies vindicate
the righteous and make all things new. That's what
Jesus is going to do.
So when you're talking about the day of the Lord Jesus Christ is
the same function God Appears in judgment and salvation.
He's going to vindicate the righteous and
he's going to judge the wicked.
He's going to say no to the wrongs of our world.
And he's gonna make everything right?
That's the day of the Lord.
The day of the Lord tells us the wrongs of our world will be set to
rights and God in Christ will make all things
new.
But that brings us back to verse 12 doesn't this is the second
Reflection from this passage?
Remember verse 12. What does it say?
Who can endure it?
Who can endure the day of the Lord?
Well, that's where we get the Deep Cries of the
title of our talk today.
The second Reflection from this passage is God desires
our repentance and prayer.
When you look at verse 2 chapter 2 verses 12
through 14, you see this language the language of return return.
God desires our repentance.
Look at the text. It says get even now declares
the Lord return to me with all your heart with fasting
with weeping with mourning ringe your hearts. Not your
garments return to the Lord your God for he is gracious and merciful
slow to anger abounding and steadfast
love and he relents over disaster. Now, some will say
well, there's no real explicit mention of sin. So this probably isn't
talking about repentance. Well, actually it is
The reason is there's probably five good reasons
why this is really talking about repentance, even though no explicit
sin has been mentioned number one.
Anytime you're talking about this Locust or enemy Invasion. It
reminds us of Deuteronomy and Leviticus and
Covenant curse. So that when we
see or hear Locust plague the memory is oh, yeah that's happening
Covenant curse for Israel. The second reason is
because the language and Joel 115
alas or in Hebrew. It's aha right?
Not like aha Eureka found it,
but that's more what it's going on.
This indicates surprise not
surprised but rather Terror at God's judgment over
sin in other texts in the Old Testament.
You also see in chapter in Chapter
2 here this language that shows up in 12
to 14 is The Exodus 34 language
and it indicates God's covenant of commitment
to his people after they've committed sin and I'll
unpack that in just a minute.
Which means that after God's people repent?
of sin
God reaffirms his Covenant character with them.
Fourth reason the language here is
very similar to what you find in Jeremiah and
Jeremiah is always talking about repentance. So
again, just looking at cortex. We're drawing
from the Old Testament the language that he's
talking about is probably repentance.
And then very clearly in verse 13 who knows
God May relent over disaster that
language that phrase in verse 13 relenting over
disaster and Punishment and sin is the
same language used in the Book of Jonah.
to describe what happened to the ninevites after
They repented of their sin.
Jonah was upset about that. He was kind of a racist if
you want to know the honest truth.
So all those reasons tell us that what's going
on here is repentance. God desires
repentance and verse 13
pictures that in a very interesting way.
Look at what it says. It says ring your
hearts.
Not your garments not have you ever thought about
what that would mean Rend your hearts that mean you reach inside
yourself and rip your heart open.
First of all, that's gruesome.
We don't want to do that. I wouldn't encourage that.
No, it's a metaphor.
And the metaphor works because in the
ancient world whenever catastrophe catastrophe with
strike or God's people were supposed to repent they
would often strip and rip their
their clothes and they would sit in
ashes and throw ashes on themselves to show their repentance.
Now what's interesting here, is that rending your
hearts and not your garments tells us that there
might have been some people who were doing some showy action.
They were ripping their shirt. They were ripping their cloak. They
were rending their garments and
probably throwing ashes on themselves and sitting on the ground
and
a bit making a big show.
But what God doesn't want from us.
Is a big external show.
He wants inner transformation of the
heart.
Now some of us in this room know what it's
like whenever in our we're talking to God, maybe you're bargaining with
God this morning.
Maybe you're saying Lord. If you just make this deal
go through. I'll say 50 Hail Marys. I'll give all my
money to the poor. I'll come to church. I'll be
a good boy. I'll be a good girl. I'll do the right thing. I'll be
a good person. I won't hurt anybody. I won't defraud
anybody. I'll do this. I'll do that. I'll do the other and really
what we're doing is bargaining with God on our terms.
Not God's terms our terms.
God we're in a business deal and I'll do this if you do
that.
That's not what this is talking about.
There's no external show that we can put on for God
for us to impress him.
What God wants who can endure the day of the Lord what God
wants is inner transformation of the heart Rend
your hearts.
Not your garments now some of us in this generation. I
work with college students every day. And
this is the kind of place where
some of our our College folks might say well God
didn't care what we do. God just
cares about our heart.
You know, I didn't care what I do.
I mean, I love him. We're good.
me and God
good.
Here's the flip side what I'm saying
about show right? God didn't care about what we
do. Yes, he does.
Why because our actions oftentimes reveal
our hearts?
So if you come to church on a Sunday.
That's great.
That's wonderful.
But it's not so you can check a box and say you're a
good person or a good Christian.
The reason we come here.
is because from the deepest core of
our being
God in Christ has transformed Our
Lives.
And our desire is to worship Him.
And what happens when we worship him and have that
inner transformation of the heart all of a
sudden life seems change.
I'll never forget whenever I was a
One of a my son played Pop Warner football
when we lived in Wake Forest North Carolina, and I was one of
the coaches for my son's Pop Warner football team and and it
was a great team. Actually a lot of those kids went D1
playing the one I see him
on Saturdays great great kids.
And one of the kids on that team.
We got to know his parents a little bit and his parents
looked great on
the outside beautiful wonderful cool people from
New York.
moved down to Wake Forest
and you know Jill and I you know, we're hanging on
by a thin thread most of the time in life. And so we're like look
at Adam and Jill says to
the our friend Christy. She said that you guys are
unbelievable. You guys look like you've got it all together. I don't know how you
do it. Are you have a faith Journey or
anything? No. No, we don't, you know.
Wow, that's amazing. I don't know how you do it.
And the more we got to know them the more we saw
there was another story behind the story that that was there
on the outside, right?
If you were to kind of relate this to something like be real
or something like that.
They needed a real
be real for their life.
Because what was going on on the outside was airbrushed and
photoshopped and everything else.
What was really going on in their family was pretty pretty
horrific.
And through the process of about a year. We got
to know them.
Through the process of about two years. We saw God do a
miracle in their life. God save the husband.
Then he saved the son.
And he saved the daughter or the wife and then
the other son.
And the reality is their life was radically transformed
and so my friend Doug. He said
he's I don't I don't know how to process this what
I'm not tell you. I'm like, okay.
He said, you know, I was watching the show
on HBO.
And I've been watching the show for years. I think it was something like Game
of Thrones.
And he said they're the scene came up.
and I just got this real uneasy feeling
I shouldn't be watching this.
And I said really?
He said yeah, what happened?
I said I'll tell you what happened Doug. The Lord has gotten
hold of your life and he's changing your desires and it's changing your actions.
And sure enough seeing the life transformation in
that family through the powerful work of
God is unbelievable.
Why because God doesn't just care about our hearts.
Our hearts then bleed over into our hands.
God cares about our hearts
and our hands it's not our hearts, but not our hands.
It's not our hands but not our hearts God cares about
both but it's the right order, isn't it?
Rend your hearts not your garments
Don't just make it external show of things if your heart's not in it likewise listen.
If you know you say your heart's in it, it better results
in something in your life.
Think about Jesus, right?
Do you remember what happened when he visited Zacchaeus?
Jesus didn't say Zacchaeus. I'll come to your house if
You give all the money to the poor and you you know,
give money back with interest with those
who you've defrauded. He didn't say that did he?
What did he see? He sees Zacchaeus and he says Zacchaeus. I'm
gonna have a meal at your house today.
And Zacchaeus went and joyfully received him.
and then after he encount
ers this I'm gonna give all my money the poor or whatever defraud all
those people defrauded. I'm gonna give them back with interest.
When you look at Jesus, it's never a well.
I'll love you if
it's just I love you.
I want to change your life.
I want to forgive you of your sins.
And then when that happens your life
changes.
God cares about our hearts and our hands.
This phrase rinsed your hearts not your
garments return to me return to me. All this
language is telling us that inner transformation
of our hearts brings out outward devotion.
So why do we go serve the poor?
Not to be good little boys and girls.
Because Christ compels us.
the love of Christ compels us
Why are we ethical in our business?
Not so that we can Pat ourselves at the back and say well
I'm so much better than you.
No.
Because the love of Christ compels us
it motivates our action.
What happens when we Rend our hearts what happens when
we experience that inner transformation?
Verse 13 tells us this covenantal language. You
see in Joel 13. We see God as gracious
and merciful slow to anger abounding and steadfast love relenting
over punishment. Do you know that language?
God's people already know it comes from Exodus chapter 34 verses
6 and 7. You can see it there on the screen where God is
merciful that language the underlying
words in the figure that you see here on
the screen. Abounding is steadfast love for thousands for giving iniquity
transgression and sin that underline language
indicates. What's not real? What's
not reiterated in Joel's reception of The Exodus Passage?
Or we see here and this is interesting.
This language in Exodus 34 shows
up after God's people have experienced that
inner transformation. What happens is God shows up as a
god whose gracious and merciful.
Slow to anger abounding and steadfast love and mercy.
What you find here?
Is God in Exodus is all
of those things Joel picks that language up as
gracious merciful slow to anger relenting over
punishment. This is who God is.
The phrase relenting over punishment as I've said is
unique to Joel.
It's about mourning and fasting coupled with this turn
to God repentance and repentance in
prayer. If you turn to God in prayer
and fasting and weeping, then you'll see who God
is. Who is he that
prayer repentance
prayer is about relationship through prayer. God becomes our source
of Hope in a very real way in prayer. We find God Alone
provides possibility of transformation. This
is who God is
in his grace and in his Mercy
God responds to our repentance when we
Rend our hearts not our garments.
God transforms us and delivers.
When God's people pray from the heart, we see God transform the
inner person and the world around us.
The world around us. Yeah, how do we know this goes to our third reflection?
Third Reflection from this passage is God delivers mercy
and renewal.
Is God Only a God who wants to judge and condemn?
No, he's not.
In this passage particularly verses 18 through 27,
we see that God turns our tragedies into triumphs
Look at the screen here, you'll see all the tragedies listed
in chapter one. Check this out. You see this all the
tragedies of chapter one Locust versus
one four Army one six. No
new wine or grain or
oil one five.
10 or 18 there's no offering or libation
offering to the Lord. There's a morning land. There's a
groaning Beast. You can see it withered land withered crops
drought mourning people Joy is all dried
up. That's the tragedy that we see in God's people
But is that the end of the story?
No.
Look at the Divine triumphs. God works on Israel's
behalf in verses 18 through 27.
Where before there were locusts now, there is a restoration from the
Locust plague in Chapter 2 where there's an army
verse two verse 20 God drives
the northerner way where there was no grain wine or
oil now. There's a restoration of grain up wine and
oil where there was no offering or libation. Now,
there's abundance of grain wine and
oil where there was a morning land. Now, you have this language fear not.
Oh soil where there were groaning
beasts. Now, there are fear not obese to the field where there
were withered land and dry crops. Now, there's a fertile land
where there was drought. There's early and latter rain.
where there are morning people
Now there's joy and no more shame. Do you see?
What the text is telling us?
When we repent when we turn to the Lord, we trust
him when we find our shelter in him. This
is what happens God turns our
tragedies into triumphs and
only God can do that.
Yes.
I've seen this personally.
in the past week through pain and
a lot of confusion
you can see pictures there on the screen of
What our campus looked like it was?
It was bad. You know that was our business center
a wall was blown out there. You can
see Raley Chapel at Rayleigh. Chapel was
significantly impacted now that's patched up.
You can see or even our apartment complexes. You
can see that they've been impacted
and then Shawnee Hall our oldest
and most significant academic building Shawnee
Hall was impacted. Here's what she needed to know.
As I began this message listen to me class is starting
with students on campus on Monday.
Now if God can do that in a week
What do you think God can do in your life in a month?
We think God can do in your life in a year.
As you live a life of devotion or repentance to
him.
Who can endure the day of the Lord? I'll tell you who.
those who run their hearts
those who repent of their sin and those who trust in
the renewal of God. See God is good.
God is merciful.
And what we need to understand about the God that we worship.
We see this in Jesus. He likes to take Wayward
things and bring them home.
He likes to take broken things and mend them.
He likes to take us battered.
And make us better. Why?
So then we'll know who God is.
I got to tell you.
Is very personal?
I'm a
exhausted
confused. I don't understand.
But this is what I can tell you.
I know God better today.
Because of the triumphs that he brings through tragedy.
I know him today better.
Than I would isn't it interesting at the end of this section here versus 25
through 27, you know the language that
shows up.
Then you will know.
That I'm God.
I'm in the midst of Israel.
A lot of times we want to escape the hard things of life.
You don't have to escape them.
Walk through them with God and discover. He
is all we need.
dark stars Deep Cries
divine grace